>> From the Library of Congress,
in Washington, DC.
[ Silence ]
>> I'd like to go ahead and introduce
our presenters this afternoon:
Robin Butterhof is a Digital
Conversions Specialist, in the Serials
and Government Publications
Division of the Library of Congress.
She primarily works on the
National Digital Newspaper Program,
and its website Chronicling America, which
provides free public access to millions
of digitized historic US
newspaper pages from 1836 to 1922.
And, Tom Bober serves as
the Library of Congress,
2015-2016 Teacher in Residence
for Audio-Visual Materials.
A Librarian at RM Captain Elementary
School in Clayton, Missouri.
Thomas used a variety of primary sources
from the Library of Congress on historical
and scientific topics to help
students construct knowledge.
Thanks to both of you for joining.
Take it away.
>> Great. Thanks for that
fantastic introduction, Mike.
Just to put names to our faces, my name is Robin
Butterhof, and I work on Chronicling America,
that huge collection of digitized
papers that Mike was telling you about.
My co-presenter is the fantastic Tom Bober.
He's the Teacher in Residence here at LC.
So, what is Chronicling America?
Chronicling America is a website that provides
free public access to over 10 million pages
of historic US newspapers from 1836 to 1922.
So, in 1923 is when copyrights
start to get a little complicated.
That's why our particular site stops at 1922.
Too many topics that you'd be interested in for
this period like: The Titanic, or World War I,
or the Roller Skating Craze of the 19 teens.
Feel free to toss that over into the chat, and
we'll try and talk about it during the session,
just so you hear about what's
interesting to you.
So, the easiest way to get into the
Chronicling America database is just
to do a simple cure search.
As you can see here is I typed in the
word "prohibition", and this is the set
of search results that popped up.
So, one thing to keep in mind
with historic newspapers is
that you're typically doing key-word searches on
Optical Character Recognition Text, or OCR Text.
For those of you who are not very familiar
with OCR, a computer looks at the page image
and tries to guess at what words
of letters are on the page.
It's really good for printed letters.
It's not very good for handwritten letters,
or really tiny letters, or scribbling letters.
So, if you can't-- it might not pull up
every instance of your key-word on the page.
Now, Tom is going to tell you
about a different way to get
into the Chronicling America newspapers.
>> Yes, another way to search is through
"Special Topics" in Chronicling America.
Special Topics has over 250
different topics in general categories
from Crimes and Trials to Natural Disasters.
From Politics to Sports, Science,
and War, and literally hundreds more.
If you notice the screen shot on the right
shows what one of those topics page looks like.
The important dates can help with searching,
as well as provide some background information.
Suggested search strategies will
give you search terms and other tips
to conducting your own searches
on specific topics.
And, towards the bottom, sample articles are
a good entry point, but not at all the whole
of what Chronicling America has
to offer on a specific topic.
Well, not in this example.
Some topics also contain a special section
of background information on the event,
or in the time period that the
topic's page is focused on.
This can be helpful when students are using
Chronicling America to begin exploring a topic
that maybe they know very little about.
>> So, what's behind the website?
Chronicling America is a product of
the National Digital Newspaper Program.
A joint effort by the Library of Congress, and
the National Endowment for the Communities,
and their fantastic local State partners.
The States in green are our States that
currently participate in the program.
States in gray have not yet applied
for, or received a grant from any Age.
Personally I'm from New Jerseyan myself,
so I'd love to see those States
in gray join the program.
And, I'm really glad to hear that some of you
are interested in Suffrage, so I'm going to talk
about that a bit later, and I'll address the
African-American Newspapers question later
in the QA, too.
I have a really long digression
on that one for you guys.
So, just to give a quick recap, there are
over 10 million pages that have been digitized
from 40 States and Territories, that includes
Puerto Rico, and this includes content
in a number of different languages:
French, Italian, German, Spanish,
and we actually have some Finnish in there, too.
So, that's enough about Chronicling America.
Let's see we can use some of those
10 million pages in the classroom.
This particular add is part of a primary source
set created by the Library of Teaching Team.
But, this stuff is really easy to find
by searching for the word "Suffrage".
So, just sort of think about this in the
classroom, let me just to provide this
at students, and just observe; what
are some things that you notice first?
And if you guys want to type in
some responses into the chat,
that would be a great way to
sort of get things started.
For me, my favorite quote is "Who
would go if women suffrage came"?
Not the mothers.
They're too busy to engage in politics.
So after you've sort of had some initial
observations going, you might start to delve
into some observing and reflecting,
like who created this particular ad?
Why did they create it?
Who is sort of the audience for this?
And, I think you can see down at the bottom,
this Oklahoma Association
opposed to Women Suffrage.
I was really curious so I just googled
it to see what I could find, if anything,
and happily enough, the Oklahoma Historical
Society had a great article about this group,
and I'm not going to completely digress
into the article, and about this group.
But, they're mostly campaigning against the
Suffrage Movement and the Suffrage Amendment,
as you can see from this particular ad.
And it is relevant that it's an ad, too.
That's really interesting type
of content in the newspapers.
I think it really provides
a different perspective,
and it really makes your
students start to think about;
why someone paid money to
put their message out there.
So, sort of briefing beyond that,
let's look at some of the "when
and where" this particular ad was created,
as you can see, your newspaper is great
for these kinds of analysis, and the
time and location are usually right
at the top, there, if you can see.
It's the Tulsa Daily World; Oklahoma--
Tulsa, Oklahoma, and then November 3, 1918.
This is up in the folio if you want
to get all newspaper nerdy about it.
And it's great for your students
who are on the same page, as well.
So let's move beyond just
observing things and start thinking
about what this time and place means.
So, what else is going on in November 1918?
So, from this particular page and article, by
just opening up my search to November, 1918,
and searching for the word "Suffrage", I
didn't run into Oklahoma, but actually,
an Oklahoma newspaper is one of
the first things that popped up.
And, you can see that Wilber 1 is
coming to a close here, quite clearly;
that "Germany is Licked to a Frazzle".
Love that headline, and I think one
of my favorite quotes from the ad
down at the bottom right-- I think a
little too small for you to read here,
but my favorite quote is: "Women were too busy
with Red Cross work, and other work took place,
to devote much time to the Suffrage cause".
I think it's a really good exhibition that
doesn't often occur in history textbooks.
You'll sort of have the chapter on Suffrage;
the chapter on sort of history progressing.
But this really pulls it all
together into the same page,
and it really provides a rich
context for the students.
So, the "observe with respect" questions on
the last couple of slides where is inspired
by The Teachers' Guides start
analyzing newspapers.
This guide is up on the Library of Congress
Teachers' Site, and is a great way to build
out an article-- build out a lesson on an
article that you're particularly inspired by.
I'd also really recommend the ones on political
cartoons if that's what strikes your fancy,
because they're a lot of questions about
visual literacy that are much more relevant
than a political cartoon sort on analysis.
So, we we're open that this backed up, and see;
what are some of the benefits that you find
from using these papers in the
classroom, or what are some ways
that you would use newspapers
in an instructional setting?
Let me hand this over to Tom to
sort of lead off this conversation.
>> Thanks, Robin.
So, like Robin said, we'd love for you to put
down into the chat box some ways that you think,
and beyond the topics, how you might
use newspapers in the classroom,
or some ideas that maybe
you've had about using them.
We're going to talk more specifics about those
later, and while you're actually doing this,
I thought I might just go over some
general ideas of ways you can use them,
along with some specifics that I've
used with students over the years.
So, one way to use Chronicling America is
to take an idea from another primary source,
and use Chronicling America to go in depth.
>>There are a multitude of
resources on one specific topic.
There could literally be hundreds of
articles, and so you will find an area of depth
within Chronicling America that in many cases,
you won't find anywhere else
in the Library's collection.
I love what Jacob said, too; another great
way to demonstrate opposing viewpoints.
There's definitely going to be different
ideas; different perspectives when you have
that many resources out there, and
that's another great thing to look at.
For example, my students who were doing
some research on the Statue of Liberty,
and looking at the time when it was built, were
reading about people who were vehemently opposed
to building the Statue, thinking that it was
anti-religious to build a statue that large,
and that grand that represented liberty.
Also, it allows ways to see changes in
reaction over time; same with that same topic,
there are great articles in Chronicling
America about how upset people were,
as the Statue of Liberty began to change in
color from what we think is a copper color,
to that tinted green copper that
we see when we look at it today.
Advertising and news stories
can show what people value.
How much do things cost?
You compare this with a historic
currency calculator,
and that can provide even more
understanding about information.
It's also important to look at whose
side was represented in the story.
But, whose side was not reported on?
We've also looked at smaller inquiries such as;
the question came up about whether the
children were really sent through the mail--
based on some stories that
were read out of our library.
And they've looked at huge
topics such as; World War I.
Although, of course, they wanted to
look at the search upon the Great War
in Chronicling America, and with
so much information in there,
it was overwhelming unless
you modify your searches.
We'll take a look and talk
more about that later.
Robin, I'm going to hand it back to you.
>> Great. Thanks, Tom.
Oh, my goodness, and there's so much
good stuff going on in the chat.
They're definitely going to
get to that in the Q and A. So,
I wanted to talk about another reason why
newspapers are a particularly great kind
of primary source, and that reason is:
because they're short; they're brief;
the content is super short and accessible,
particularly in terms of vocabulary.
This makes for a really easy
pairing of other newspaper articles,
or other types of primary sources.
As you can see right here, there is a
great image from a Philadelphia paper.
The image up at the top, this
is a Montana Suffrage paper
that was published during
the Montana State Fair.
I think there are only four issues of
it, and each issue was a fantastic way--
the energy was just so great
in that particular newspaper.
And then, at the bottom, we have this newspaper
from Florida, with the representatives talking
about how sensitive adversity is
really growing in favor of Suffrage,
and it's just really interesting to sort of put
all these things together, and have these things
to read and work with them fairly quickly.
News clippers are also really great
for another reason, and that reason is;
multiple perspective, which I think someone
was talking about in the chat, actually,
as you can see here, is that article
from the Oklahoma paper, before.
Then we have this great image off to the left
about a headquarters for the Association opposed
to Women's Suffrage over in Pennsylvania.
And so this is actually from the same newspaper
paper of the image on the overhead slide.
So, just on the same newspaper page
you'll see opposing viewpoints.
This makes for some really easy caparisoning
contrast options for your students.
So, the breath of Chronicling
America is also really great
because it makes a local option possible.
If you just want to look at the Suffrage fight
in Montana, you can just focus on Montana.
We have plenty in there.
I do actually love Montana for Suffrage, all
things considered, and it really brings it home,
the local aspect for your students.
You're just not reading about
something big happening in Great Falls;
you're reading about all across the country.
Newspapers are also really
great for digging deeper.
This is another item from the
primary source set on Suffrage,
and how it's a great option on its own.
You can see things about the
information of the image.
You can tell that it was
captured on May 4th, 1912.
You can see it's a Suffrage
parade in New York City,
but you don't get a ton of
information beyond that.
So, let's say you take this image, and
after the students have sort of looked at,
and explored it, pair it with the New
York Tribune from the Hall on Monday.
You can see here, there's a
ton of coverage of the parade.
You've got these great cartoons off
the left, this article on the right
about this humanizing effect of Suffrage,
how the parade impressed many Senators,
and it's just a really great way to you
can be billed out on a particular image
that you're inspired by, as well.
So, we talked about all the reasons why
newspapers-- well, not all of them--
I could come up with reasons all day long.
There are a couple of reasons why
newspapers can be tricky in the classroom.
Some of the reasons they can
be tricky is insert language.
As you can see in this example: Airplanes were
once called "Aeroplanes", and as Tom was talking
about earlier; it was called the
"Great War", rather than World War I.
We can figure if students went
searching for the word "Airplane",
they wouldn't necessarily find much.
In addition to your unfamiliar signs
or terms, there can often be difficult
or fun-fist language in the newspapers, and,
Tom is going to talk a bit more
about both of these things.
>> So, one thing that students should be doing
when reading newspaper articles is always to be
on the lookout for historic language.
It will likely not be as obvious
as the newspaper headline, here,
which I happened to run across this one
searching "Aeroplane", and " Airplane".
The terms we are familiar with today often
accompany terms that have fallen out of favor.
As example; on reading two articles on
automobiles, I also found the following terms:
Horseless Carriage, Electric Carriage,
Electric Motor Buggy, Motor Wagon, Road Wagon,
Automobile, Auto-car, and Moto cycle.
That gives me many, many more searches
that I can try, and continue to dig deeper.
The danger is not not running
into the information in my mind
when my students are searching; the danger
is not finding that one additional article
that will be a great resource
for them and their learning.
Remember that Recommended Topics and,
Sherry, thank you for that recommendation,
and Chronicling America, also
contain search terms and tips,
that they themselves, are not an exhausted list.
Students are also likely to run across
unfamiliar words and phrases found
in Chronicling America, and they can be searched
right within Chronicling America, itself.
Context clues within the article
can often provide great information.
And, of course, students can do web
searches also to help find that definition.
But, when they do find definitions,
check to make sure
that the definitions are from
that specific time period.
Because often we have words, excuse me--
that have changing meanings over time.
Offensive language in sensitive topics are
definitely present in the 10 million pages
of Chronicling America, and while you
have some control over what students see
if you're selecting the articles,
if students are searching,
or if the topic you are searching
lends itself to offensive language,
I would really recommend the two blog posts from
the Teaching with the Library of Congress blog,
that can help you address
these issues with students.
Those two blog posts are linked there, and as
Mike mentioned earlier, those will be available
in the archive of the post, as well.
>> So, we should present also "tricky",
because it can be really difficult
to find the really juicy stuff, like
political cartoons or photographs.
So, as I explained earlier, the key-words
here, are the OCR text, and as you can see
in this example, political cartoon on the right.
You can see that these two fellows are
claiming their summer vacation based
on what counties were still serving alcohol,
and which parts of the country were
not serving alcohol at that point,
so that's in the dry counties, and you can
see his comment down here; it's all on account
of being here, suffragettes, and if you
were searching for the words suffragette,
this particular political cartoon wouldn't come
up, because it is sort of a form of a word that,
you know, not the proper spelling,
and that's a little handwritten text,
so that the OCR is probably
not going to pick up his word,
and bring it up if you search for suffragette.
So, instead, I found this article
when I was sort of browsing around it,
and I just see to my personal tumbler, see
it because there's so much good stuff going
on here; you've got prohibition,
and you've got the suffragettes,
I just knew I would want
to use it at some point.
>> And you may use it on an
interest board or something else.
But you see a couple of political
interest boards with stuff like this.
So, it can also be really
hard to find photographs.
Has anyone ever heard of Dazzle Camouflage?
It's a kind of camouflage that
came around during World War I,
to make it difficult to accurately
target a ship.
It's really fun to read about, I have to say.
And, when I went hunting for dazzle
ships in Chronicling America,
searching for the word "dazzle" brought up a
ton of dazzling things, which were not trips,
and it didn't bring up as much as I was
thinking would come up, and then I realized
when it brought up words with "dazzle
ship" included the word "camouflage".
So, then I started searching all the terms
with camouflage to see if I could get something
to pop up, and as you can see
from this particular image,
the caption doesn't include the word "dazzle
ship", it just includes the word "camouflage".
And, it's really easy to run
into this problem with images.
They may have no caption at all, or a
really short caption, a handwritten caption.
So, you really have to be curious when
going through a refined search if you've got
to pursue images of certain things.
And Tom is going to talk a little
bit more about both of these topics.
>> So, that search for work
camouflage is going to result
in several images that maybe interesting.
And so what I like to do when I'm
looking at search results like this,
is to actually search the visual images.
Look for those images that catch the eye;
that make you want to investigate further,
and then look carefully at the
captions that accompany those images.
Those are going to result,
hopefully, in new search terms.
Also, I like to look for repeated images,
reading multiple captions of that same image
from different newspapers, can yield
more information about that moment.
So, if you look at my first two
search results in the top row,
you'll notice that "dazzle
ship", that Robin shared with us,
is found in both of those newspapers, and
actually has two different captions, there.
One other thing that Robin mentioned
is the difficulty in looking
and finding information within cartoons.
Now, some of these cartoons may be searchable,
depending on the clarity of the printed word
within them, and their ability to be recognized
by the softwares that they're digitized with.
You might want to search with the newspapers
where you've already found a political cartoon
that you like, or that you found engaging.
Like Robin mentioned; when you
stumble across those, put them aside.
You may be using them not immediately,
but maybe later in the year, or
in the following school year.
And with so many engaging stories on each page,
save links to those pages that contain stories
that you can incorporate, or that maybe
colleagues can incorporate in other units.
It's also a wonderful way to show the complex
interconnected events of a time period.
Now, let's stay with that topic with the
event of the 1906 San Francisco Earthquake,
that we saw mentioned in that last cartoon,
to demonstrate another tricky situation.
Large numbers of search result.
Here, a simple search of the San Francisco
Earthquake yields almost 8,000 results.
That's not close to the over 1 million results
for Robin's prohibition search earlier,
but it's still too many for
me or my students to manage.
Working with the advanced search can help
narrow results, refining the dates of;
when you want to view the
cultural impact of an event.
Refining your own ideas of
the specificity of the event.
Both of those things can be helpful, although
it may require you to make multiple searches
with different specific focuses
within the event, itself.
You might want to think; do you want to
see newspapers only from a specific State?
Or, even a specific newspaper.
You might want to look at how ideas
manifested in a certain region,
or within how they manifested over time
within one region, or State, or newspaper.
And don't forget, also, that there's a checkbox
where you can only look at the front page
of a newspaper if you just
want to see those headlines.
When looking at the search results,
look at the highlighted text.
Does the amount of highlighted text
show you how much a story is covered?
Can you tell if the search
terms are part of a headline?
Part of an advertisement?
Maybe they show up about multiple stories.
If you can, read the headlines.
Look at dates of publication, as
well as location of publication,
and you may see patterns, or
repeated images for stories
that were printed in multiple newspapers.
>> Okay. Great, Tom.
So, what happens if you're really excited about
all these things, but you're not really sure
where to start, or if you run into a problem;
I'd really recommend using
our "Ask-a-Librarian" feature.
This sends a question to our reference veterans,
and they're happy to help get you started
or find resources that you
didn't even know existed.
We've all seen these questions
coming from teachers
that are always really good and interesting.
Another helpful thing might be the Recommended
Topics page that Tom was talking about.
There's some great ones, like, I think someone
was interested in the early history of radio,
some Marconi, and of related, I think
some people were talking about science,
Nicholas Heffler's a fun one,
the invention of the telephone.
There's some really fun ones like electricity,
and how electricity is spread throughout
the country, and all the things
that weren't electrified
before being electrified now.
Great ads on that one, by the way, and
I'll show you one of those at the end.
We used to get a ton of questions
from National Day History Students via
"Ask-a-Librarian" service, and we can usually
direct them to an already existing topics page.
Of course, if we don't have them, we
help out with your specific questions.
But, it's really surprising how many topics
we've already addressed through these pages.
Another great page is the Teachers Site,
without Analyzing Newspapers Teachers Guide,
we were talking about earlier, and the Teaching
Blog; with those blog posts about dealing
with difficult subjects in primary sources.
I love those, and it's actually a two-part set.
The first one was written, and
then so many people responded.
There's a part of that blog post
on their response to dealing
with difficult subjects in the classroom.
This is just sort of a quick
sum-up link of all of those sites,
and then there's some specific things
that you might be interested in, as well.
On the primary source sets, I
collect the set on Women's Suffrage.
These are all different primary source
sets, and what the plans include
from content from Chronicling America.
The Spanish-American War is fantastic
to look at, via the newspapers,
and those blogs that I was talking about
earlier, with dealing with difficult subjects.
The "Twelve Years a Slave" is a great one.
I love those blog posts, and I'm just going
to stop here on a side of all different kinds
of Chronicling America, so my
days of things that I've seen.
Up at the top we have the simple word beginning,
Teddy Roosevelt, forming the Bull Moose Party,
the Titanic sinking, there's a lot of
panic about Hayley's Comet coming so close
to the earth, and the atmosphere incinerating,
and all sorts of other dire things happening.
Lots of sports history, and as I was talking
about earlier, the electric revelation,
sort of electricity spreading throughout the
United States, and the electric car, over here.
So, I can see there are a ton of questions in
the chat, and I'll just get started with those.
So, Mike has collected a bunch of fantastic
ones for us, and the first one I will address is
from Vanessa Palmer, and: Do you have access
to American owned and operated newspapers?
So, yes. We do actually have a
bunch of African-American newspapers
in the Chronicling America database.
I'd recommend going to the Algebratized
newspapers Chat, which I would show you,
but I can't go to the live-type
via this, with our software, there.
And, once you're there, click on "Algebratized
Newspapers", and there should be a sort
for African-American newspapers, and then
we just actually added a great newspaper
by Frederick Douglas for
the reconstruction period,
which I worked on a lot,
and really, really loved.
And, so that is a fantastic resource to look at.
And actually, so, I'll read the question,
and then pass this one over to Tom.
This is from Shaquilla.
[Phonetic] What are appropriate topics to teach
to elementary-aged students, using newspapers?
Do we use current newspapers?
Tom?
>> Thanks, Robin.
So, I am normally an Elementary
School Librarian, and so, really,
the only limits that you really have, as far
as topics are concerned, is your curriculum.
When I am working with classroom teachers,
and working on incorporating primary sources
in a classroom, Chronicling America often comes
up, and as a resource, and finding topics,
or if a topic fits with what Chronicling
America has to offer, it's going to be great.
>> No holds barred.
I will say that we have run into
some issues, so, for example;
I was trying to find the earliest reference
I could find in Chronicling America
to Paul Bunion, because we were
going to be looking at, "Tall Tales",
and that particular story that was printed in
the newspaper, while extremely interesting,
had offensive language that the
teachers and I were not willing to use
with that particular age of students.
If the students were a little bit older,
we probably would have incorporated it in,
and talked about that offensive language,
and how we deal with it as historians.
But, given the background that
those students had, we chose not to.
The other thing that you want to take
into consideration is simply how
much text you're giving them, and so,
Robin did mention that these
particular-- often, the articles are short.
You will sometimes find articles
that are literally a page long.
They're quite hefty, and so
you want to steer maybe away
from those with certain ages of students.
But, what I've also done sometimes is
when the article, itself, is too hefty,
we look at the illustrations, the photos, the
headlines, and those can be analyzed as well,
and are much more available, and
accessible to younger students.
And, Robin?
Do we have another question?
>> We do, indeed.
There's another very good one that--
>> Oh, sorry.
Go ahead.
>> Okay.
>> Sorry, Robin.
>> Oh, yeah.
I'll tackle Art Riches question about
describing technological changes
by decade, especially the uses of images.
So, I'm not sure if you're referring
to general technological changes,
or changes in misprinting technology.
I would think a lot of people are surprised
when they start looking at the older newspapers
about what you find in terms of a headline,
or things that we sort of consider common
in newspapers, hadn't been invented yet.
When we the weather column, I think I
found the first national weather column
when they started sending things back and
forth by telegram, and it was very cool.
So, the weather column was
invented, it wasn't really headlines,
earlier in the day, it would be much smaller.
So, if you're looking for a headline
about the Civil War, it's probably going
to be fairly restrained,
compared to what you would expect.
The extra over here is about
as big as it will get.
But, there were other things that
they would use in newspapers, as well.
They had something called "Morning bars".
So, outside of the column,
there would be a black border
around any notification, or funeral notice.
So, if you look at the newspapers or on the
death of Lincoln, you'll see this black boarder
around all the columns on the page, because
that was how they would tip away death notices.
So, a lot of things changed in newspapers,
and images really started to play a role in,
I want to say, after 1900,
there was some before then,
but that's when they really
started to get going.
And, newspapers around World War I would
have these fantastic border group sections.
So, they would just be for eight pages
of images from visual fun themes,
to other common things happening in the US.
So, there was a lot of other versions
in what a newspaper is over the period
that you can see in Chronicling America.
So, I'm not sure if that was quite
your question, but there is a lot
on interesting stuff packed in there.
I'm going to give you over to Mike for a second.
I think he said there was some more questions.
>> Let's reach out another one, will
Chronicling America ever add more recent papers?
>> I'm assuming he means those, too.
>> Yeah. So, with copyright being
what it is, it's very complicated,
and these papers are an even more complex
object in that they're complications
of things pulled from, you know,
the Associated Press, you know,
images from staff reporters, ads.
Different people might own the different
copyright aspects of different parts
of the papers, or like a cartoonist might have
kept the copyright to his particular things.
So, after when came 22 themes
did get complicated.
That said, there are kind of companies
like; New York Times, Washington Post,
that had digitized their archives, and are
up and available as subscription sources
through your local public or academic
library that you might want to explore.
I know there are tons of things
happening in the 40s, 50s, 60s, 70s,
and 80s, that people love to look at.
That's why we're sticking
to 1922 with our database.
>> So, here's another question, and
they're really pouring in, here.
So, Jacob asks why there are tags
associated with all the papers,
or are we just searching the
papers for text, themselves?
>> So, you've just been searching the
text with the newspapers, themselves,
we don't really have tags like you
would see on Flicker or something.
But, we do have pages that
we've pushed to Flicker.
We have pictures forwarded from LC now,
and I think you can tag those with tags
if you want to save certain things.
[ Silence ]
>> From Sarah, she asks: How easy items
like music reviews could be
found in cataloged newspapers?
>> One rule I can say this, and very good, this
is a really good thing if you want to research.
It depends on what kind of music
reviews you're looking for, but yes,
music reviews are definitely in there.
I think we have a page or two on, with the
recommended topics page on Sissieretta Jones,
which was a famous opera
singer, and there are a lot
of other very interesting bits
of musical history in there.
A lot of the premiers were in
Europe, for certain kinds of music,
so it will be sort of secondary reporting.
But, yes, there's a lot in
terms of music reviews.
>> On the list, I'm giving them to
you in order they were received.
But, Sherry asks: How the
recommended topics were chosen?
Because she thinks the articles
are so well chosen.
>> Well, there's a pretty good reason for that.
The recommended topics pages
are created by someone thinking
that the recommended topics page needs
to exist here at the Library staff,
so it's like if someone would be like-- oh,
I can't believe they don't have a topics page
on "X", and then they just
go and write a page on "X".
So, the people who are really enthusiastic
about a topic, I really got excited about the
"Pure Food and Drug Act", and which is a
great one as Halloween is around the corner.
But, pretty much Pure Food and Drug Act made
sure that, you know, cyanide wasn't in candy,
and lots of other Food and
Health Safety Regulations
that I really, really, really enjoyed.
I'd really recommend you reading it, because I
think it's a lot of fun, and it involves a story
about a doctor and his poison squad.
So, it's always a great way to start.
>> From Jason: Does anybody have any
ideas how to incorporate newspapers
into physical education classroom?
>> I'm going to hand this one over to Tom.
>> Oh, Robin.
I'm chuckling.
That is a tough one.
I think the place where it might
be interesting would be to look
at kind of exercise crazes of the day.
I'm not really well-versed enough
to know what some of those may be.
I'd probably have to go out
and do some searches,
and some other people may be putting some in--
oh, health issues, definitely,
Dana, thank you for that.
But, looking at; what were
the exercises of the day?
What were people doing for
physical activity of the day?
I think can be fascinating.
Because those things change, and they
morph, and they turn into new things.
>> I'm going to totally chime in.
I like where you went with that.
Yes, there is this great ping pong creativity
of a recommended topics page on that.
We have one on the Villa Cruiser Craze,
which I mentioned, and there are some great,
really interesting ideas about what
physical education was, and actually dance,
now that I'm thinking of
the Modern Dance Movement.
There's a particular dance word that's escaping
me, but there's a ton of great information
on dance; what suitable exercises
were for good posture,
and it might be very interesting
from that perspective.
You could do some of the physical exercises they
recommend, in these newspapers that would be on,
okay, in most cases, but in some, it might
not be very healthy for you, thought.
>> I want to jump in on one thing, and add
just one more layer to this, that Rich, here,
puts some information about the changes
in rules and purposes of sports.
>> There's some wonderful articles on,
about football, during that time period
because of how dangerous it was,
and partially because of the play,
and partially because of
the equipment and changes
that were put into place because of that.
So, that time period is really ripe with
football, if you're interested in that.
And actually, next week on the teaching the
Library of Congress blog, are other teachers
and residence, Trace Smith is
going to be posting up some--
putting up a blog post that will also contain
some resources from Chronicling America.
>> I read about Kellogg's
starting a new cereal company, too.
I read the history around that is fascinating,
and now you see a lot of great food ads
in Chronicling America's vault for
things that are still around today, from;
Wrigley's to varieties beer--
Wrigley's Gum to varieties of beer.
So, there are some really,
really fascinating ones.
We, just in a blunt post, I think on
the main Alty Bolog page about coffee.
Whiskey is also supposed to give a
cure if you're feeling summer tired,
which we didn't know that being summer tired
would be a problem until we started finding ads
for this particular kind of Whiskey.
So, yeah. If you're interested in food history,
Chronicling America is one interesting place.
The history of pastas, actually, too; just
what's considered macaroni, how you cook pasta.
Yeah, we all love the food things
a lot in Chronicling America.
[ Silence ]
>> I'm going to go ahead and jump in real
quick if I could, Mike, if that's okay,
and just address something coming up way early
in the chat window, and that was the idea
of anniversaries of special events.
Some people mentioned that they were interested
in looking at the American Revolution,
for example, and with Chronicling
America, only covering 1836 through 1922,
you're not going to get the actual events of
the American Revolution as primary sources.
But, what we can look at is how people from
1836 through 1922, viewed those individuals,
viewed those events, and how
those views changed over time.
I've done a little bit of
research for a 5th grade teacher
who is doing some work specifically
with that, with her students,
and looking at George Washington, and how
he was viewed, and how he was essentially--
kind of the mythology of George Washington,
and how it shows itself in newspapers
over decades, and it is fascinating.
So, even if you are studying
earlier time periods,
Chronicling America may still have some
avenues for you to incorporate some
of their content into your teaching.
>> I see that for the simple words here,
that we see things of the Civil War Soldiers,
50 years afterwards, and it was
really interesting to read stories
about Civil War Veterans going
back to where they had fought,
and they sort of remembrances
is associated with that.
I'd like to see the question from Jamie about
if musical event for advertising newspapers,
and yeah, there are really advertisements
for musical events, and newspapers.
There are also a bunch in--
about in movies, too.
There are some really great sections about
movies, and movie premiers, in the 19 teens,
and 1920 to '22, that provide a really
interesting view into thematic history.
There's another tint that I was going to
go on, but I think I've lost my attention.
>> Robin, Tom?
Do you have any kind of final ideas for
the good of the cause before we wrap it up?
>> I'll jump in with one more thing, as I
was making notes and watching that chat go
by from earlier, and it kind of goes along
with what Robin was mentioning at the beginning
of the presentation with all the
great resources on Women's Suffrage.
Someone mentioned looking at ideas
related to sexism and racism,
and just to note that while you, at times, you
may find specific stories that directly deal
with those events, also looking at stories
that show who is not represented in the news.
Who's not being talked about.
Whose kind of being ignored, or underreported,
can also give some support to those ideas
that have been sexism and racism.
That is another avenue that
you may want to look towards.
So, that is just one additional little note
that I had written down I wanted to throw in,
and Robin, I'm handing it off to you.
>> So, this feels important, the final word.
Newspapers, they're really great
for so many different things.
Every time I start poking around in there, I
find another six things that I try to blog,
and then I have to go write a topics page on it.
But, yeah.
I think that's-- we chatted
about a lot of the things I love,
so, I think I'll leave it at that.
>> Well, Robin and Tom.
That was an awesome presentation.
Thank you so much, and bigtime kudos
to everybody in the chatroom, too.
That was, the chat was really
beneficial, as well, and going crazy.
So, anyway, thanks everybody for being here.
I would like to invite you this time
to, you know, look at the screen,
and click the survey link, and
provide feedback on this session.
It's very valuable to us.
So, again, thanks very much for joining
us, and hope everybody has a good evening.
Bye-bye.
[ End of Session ]